this guy spent over two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars on fake ghouls
and today he's making tens of millions
of dollars in e-commerce what did he
spend the money on 130 000 on tony
robbins special one-on-one coach and
going with him to the himalaya joe
dispenza in mexico flirt coaching
fitness coaching sleep coaching habit
coaching so what can he tell us about
the guru industry that no one else knows
and what made him successful
the difficulty here is to find the right
information you know there are now this
big trend in the recent years like
everyone can call himself coaches and
they do so and even people from his
close circle have become fake gurus in
his own business he was not successful
at all but then later he was selling
like high ticket courses and coachings
to help people develop their own freedom
ridiculously expensive you don't trust
them anymore i was always hoping let
this be what i need for being finally
happy and successful so what eventually
made him successful when dennis and i
were starting out we somehow figured out
how to find the right information we
found this amazing podcast showed us 80
of what we needed to know two years
later i exited my business and he kept
building his into a gazillion dollar
empire and there are three crucial
things you have to know to find the gold
information and the third one just
recently allowed me to get mentored by
the most successful youtuber on the
planet jimmy is that you yes sir
here's the first one see when me and
dennis were starting out as clueless
entrepreneurs i found this guy on
youtube who was the perfect example of a
fake guru 0 to 1 million in 12 months
showing case studies leading to a sales
page to put in your email with lots of
people exposing him in the comments but
instead of just putting him in a box i
stayed open-minded and checked out his
podcast and he taught solid business
principles that changed everything for
me he was so transparent he was genuine
we ended up flying to austin in 2016
after our businesses started taking off
and we went to capcom it was full of
legit entrepreneurs the speakers were
amazing and i don't know if i could have
grown my business to seven figures and
eventually exited without his help what
would you tell these people who put you
in the same box well i think they're
right to be skeptical i've made way more
money doing stuff then teaching it the
dirt comes up in our industry is when
somebody makes the majority of their
money selling to other people how to
make money if you want to find the
resources that help you crush it you
have to learn this first skill a lot of
people think very black and white
someone sells a course scam their price
ends in a seven that's mind control they
had a failed business before trust
reality is never so simple but it's
black and white it's always some shade
of gray with white dots and some black
sprinkles on top and this skill is the
secret to rapid and deep learning which
is nuanced thinking just because someone
sells a course with big promises doesn't
mean they're a scam and don't give good
advice just because someone is a
successful entrepreneur doesn't mean
their advice is good and just because
someone had a failed marriage doesn't
mean they give terrible relationship
advice some of these gurus know how to
sell build a personal brand grow a cult
like following which you can learn so
much from if you just observe them no
one's thinking allows you to learn from
anyone and when i asked you guys for
your opinion on coaches and courses it's
really cool to see how many of you are
nuanced thinkers but before i tell you
the second point you're probably like
give me specific people i don't want to
think for myself tell me
so here's a few people we have jeff
hoffman built multiple billion dollar
companies dan sullivan and peter
diamandis incredible and i think the
number one person who taught me the most
about life tony robbins going to date
with destiny was i have to say it it was
life-changing it really was who do you
think is legit tim ferriss gary keller
brian handbrooks
arnold i'm all schwarzenegger i want to
learn directly from the people in the
top of their field and you might be like
but they don't give you the practical
step-by-step instructions and it's true
they talk about the fundamental
principles that are crucial still
want to know where to find the really
practical stuff
google
all the small step-by-step instructions
you need are out there so many newbies
think it's about the tactics and the
how-to but that's maybe two percent of
it learning the solid business
principles that's the important part but
how do you know you're learning from the
right people for that you need the
second skill i call it information
filtering and i mention it in this video
as well how do they find the right
information man my heart goes out to
those people who are asking that
question because that was me so he has
six very rough guidelines look at what
their businesses are that are creating
wealth and if they have them number one
do they have the result that i want
somebody who is teaching these upfront
but actually has real businesses behind
the curtain alex hormozy is another one
of these guys my name's alex remozy i'm
the owner of allen gym launch prestige
labs and five other portfolio companies
and i have absolutely nothing to sell
you for newer entrepreneurs look for
people who have taught people from where
you are to where you want to go let's
say you struggle with laziness or
self-doubt who do you think you should
listen to gary vee who was on fire the
second he plopped out of the womb i'm
gonna make monday morning my working
non-stop the day he was born or tom
bilyeu who started out lazy without
discipline overweight and then built a
billion dollar company thirdly how
credible and smart are the people who
take the advice if your weird uncle
tells you that drinking your own pee is
healthy take it with a grain of salt the
advice not to pee and that's the danger
of free advice on reddit because it only
focuses on how many people are upvoting
and agreeing with one opinion without
knowing anything about who these people
are for all you know you could be
getting fitness advice from the wrong
people number four do i trust their
intentions and this is probably the
hardest one do i really trust this
person wants me to succeed also look at
their incentives and biases the guys
exposing the gurus aren't gods and
angels just there to save you either
they also have their own agenda
including me
sorry they're primarily entertainment
channels who are incentivized to show
the drama because that's what people
want to see which video are you more
likely to click on i wasted 50 000 on
fake gurus or how to make better
judgments on how
advice to listen to and number six
cross-reference the information try to
find many sources the more you learn the
more patterns you notice is this
reasonable what is the evidence that
exists to support with this and do i
think within my current context it is
applicable so when you see all these
amazing ceos hammering the fact that you
need to have an awesome product but some
guru tells you you can sell food dishes
pots pans yeah you know that makes sense
like so why invest in any coaching if
everything is out there here's the
problem once you've built a business and
you want to grow further you won't find
the stuff you need in the first search
results on google or youtube at that
point you'd be stupid not to hire an
expert or join a mastermind without this
i wouldn't have achieved nearly as much
as i achieved now there's a reason why
someone like alex homozy has spent over
seven hundred thousand dollars on
coaching i'm a product of e-learning
buying books and seminars and and
workshops but for the newbies here's a
rule of thumb if you can't succeed offer
free information and at least get it off
the ground then you have a completely
different problem that's very well said
leon i couldn't agree more no course or
coach is gonna fix that because you like
the third and most important thing which
got me in touch with mr beast everything
i've told you so far is obsolete if you
don't get this one thing down
the first information marketing thing
that i ever purchased was a weekend in
vegas three thousand dollars you'll make
ten thousand dollars in the weekend or
i'll give you your money back that was
the guarantee and i went with a friend
of mine we go through the whole weekend
and neither of us made ten thousand
dollars but i learned how to run
facebook ads he asked for his money back
i did not we are in very different
positions in our life and so the
question is was that we can scan
[Music]
the way that most people should see
things is that everything exists on a
normal curve so you've got your outliers
on the front and you've got outliers on
the back end so it doesn't matter how
good you are this person will never
succeed right and this person will
succeed no matter what because of who
they are it is more prudent for the
people who want to learn to try and move
themselves this way so that no matter
what you do you will get a return on it
even if it's terrible i will learn what
not to do so how do we become one of
these people who succeed no matter what
when i was starting out on youtube i was
really struggling why were my videos not
getting more views so i thought it's
because of the algorithm i'm not getting
any traffic so i ran youtube ad posted
on reddit shared it on facebook and
there were countless of resources that i
found that were helpful but still things
weren't moving forward and i had to
figure it out do i lack a belief do i
like trait or do i like skill where is
the deficiency in my skill sets required
to be successful and after months of
this i learned it had nothing to do with
the algorithm it was because i lacked
the skills to make good videos they just
didn't deserve any views so then i
focused on building my skills and it
paid off i was only able to improve
because i had some level of this third
component which is self-awareness i
might have the world's best portion on
copywriting but if copywriting is not
the weakness in your business you could
buy the course on copywriting and make
no more money whose fault is there
self-awareness is the foundation of any
personal growth without it you don't
know what you're lacking therefore what
advice you should listen to so you keep
working on the wrong things
because advice could be great for most
people but the exact opposite of what
you should do somebody could tell you to
work harder but if you're someone who's
already an obsessive worker and you're
burning out what you should do is
probably take some time off and meditate
the best way i found to develop more
self-awareness is journaling and i'll
put a link down below to the journaling
exercises that i use that helped me with
that and then something happened that
changed everything for me mr beast sent
me a message
this guy with almost 70 million
subscribers calls a guy who at the time
had only 15 000 subscribers
why is that hey jimmy is that you
yes sir
for over 30 minutes jimmy took the time
to help me out without asking for
anything in return
here's a fact a lot of really successful
people want you to succeed they're
desperately looking for someone that
actually implements what they say but
it's rare that they find someone who
really does so become one of the few who
execute also make sure you check out
this video over here put a ton of work
into all of them
thanks so much for watching i'll see you
in the next one